hello and welcome to this video this is
a new video in our series here from
reddit opening of the week
battling rare first moves and we're sort
of going from the look from the black
perspective from right to left and we
looked at B 3 and B 4 and now the next
move to check is Knight to c3 yeah this
is what happens on the C file yeah white
also might play one c3 but this is so
inoculants you just play d5 if I've
whatever you want it doesn't really
interfere with black at all so 93 this
is subject of this video that move does
not have a clear name it's quite funny
it's there this is a number of names
associated with it the
fun head opening the Dunst the slide
nerd night on the left the link swinger
link swinger and dodge yeah all kinds of
weird names Wow yeah let's say not well
known names whatever it is it's not a
bad move the only reason why we don't
see this so often is that it is not very
flexible
why does committing is Knight to c3 very
early on and he also tells from with one
that is not going to use a seaport in
the fight for the center let us only
make it not so ambitious but not bad
because sorry black whatever he does
we're very often likely just to expose
to some other opening you reply to
Knight c3 can be very much adjusted to
what you play against other openings for
example if you play the Sicilian against
1.e4 then once e5 is a very decent move
as white barely has anything better then
playing a form now or on one of the next
moves sometimes they will start with the
g3 Bishop g2 but it's very logical to
play
for him so it transposes to some kind of
close Sicilian if you play however 1e5
on e4 so this looks normal
this is in fact a somewhat tricky move
here white after night and three nights
is 6d form get some yeah some weird
version of the scotch
then the pawn is not only form and that
means that some counter play is missing
that black usually has in the Scotch
here for example after move like Bishop
c5 Knight f5 is quite interesting hmm
yeah so to make it short it is not to be
recommended to play 185 on Knight c3 not
that black is in trouble but you would
really need to know some specific to
make it work if you are not averse to
1.e4 185 openings then you can play
Knight to f6 this is actually my move in
this position what I'm doing is after E
for play e5 so it's a beginner game
after d4 play d5 and it's the veresov
opening which usually arises from one d4
and besides those two moves
efore and d4 you have a hard time to
find anything that is particularly
logical I mean you can play of course f4
or something like that but the knight on
c3 and a Dutch hmm it's kind of weird
black usually does well but just
developing and like c5 96 g6 normal
moves the knight is just prematurely
placed there sometimes of course just
t-54s good kicking that night back so
after Knight c3 Knight f6 very likely
merchants opposed to some other opening
however you have to be ready for this so
you should know something about the
Vienna or yeah alternatively this is
some kind of elegance defense
sorry Knight f6 is a decent choice so C
file for the Sicilian guys Knight f6 for
the e4
five players what else is there
yeah there is my main recommendation
that is Knight c3 d5 one side note if
you intend to play with a fianchetto
like you play the the modern defense or
so I would be a little bit reluctant to
play g6 here because after h4 it looks a
bit wacky but this is probably going to
happen after age for that h5 move is
kind of annoying and probably black has
to react here somehow with h5 and I'm
not sure that you want that so if you
absolutely insist on playing for some g6
base setup maybe it's better to start
with some d6 or so even though this
looks a little bit yea modest against a
move like Knight c3 where you can play
in the center far more aggressively 95
so d5 this is my main recommendation
yeah this should also fit well with with
people who not play d5 regularly against
you for let's say yeah what is white
normally doing the most frequent move
here is the movie form and that will be
the final thing to look at
however we have to also look at other
options in some rare cases white plays
Knight to f3 just put in the second
night out here the simple recommendation
is to just play Knight f6 control D form
and if they play d4 now which looks very
likely just play for normal development
Bishop to a5 a6 and c5 is the idea it's
some kind of reverse she Guren where
White has committed very early on to put
a knight on f3 which is limiting his
option than the children quite often
that night it's not moving so early to
sometimes use the F pawn - 3 is very
rare though D forever is very valid and
this is some leading to the the rest of
opening which is this this is probably
in
some kind of somehow in your repertoire
anyway because after one deformed if we
go back most people play either d5 or
Knight f6 or sister the vast majority of
players and after d4 Knight f6 Knight c3
you're pretty much not forced but yam d5
is the most logical move there to
prevent you form so this is just another
move order to lead it to a position that
you very likely have in your repertoire
anyway I felt like I could just easily
say okay this is the rest of opening and
we are talking about rare first move so
why look at this I felt it's a little
bit like cheating because you pretty
much get it by force so I wanted to give
a quick overview what to do against
against this opening in fact it has
gotten some kind of momentum in the
recent two or three years as barrio
zubaba the very creative George and
Grandmaster has played a number of nice
games with Bishop to f4 okay let's start
however with Bishop g5 which is the
classical way to play the rest of
opening what this basically is is the
Chickering defense a tempo up yeah like
as normally playing knight c6 and Bishop
g4 and the Chico Reina this is just the
same thing colors reversed black however
has not played the typical Queens gambit
move c5 yet however this is exactly what
I recommend c5 I think this is the
probably objectively the best move Black
has a couple of alternatives like that
be g7 for example to avoid a double pawn
but if white takes on f6 we can be happy
about this we get the bishop pair and it
strengthens our center don't worry so
much about your pawn structure this is
often a mistake that that amateur
players made they have heard or learned
in some way okay
isolated pawns tablet pawns yeah this is
all true you should be aware of hip bone
structure but the piece activity is
often far more important and here black
is quite happy if white takes on f6 not
that white is worse but this is
strengthening the center and we have two
bishops in the long run
yeah how does that continue here after
energy takes white now has a basic
decision between playing III to support
the center or play aggressively with E
for after III black will play knight c6
if we start with that then
here white chooses between two moves he
plays Queen to h5 or D takes e5 if we
have a quick look how it works
if djx c5 there is a six often Bishop h5
so a Queen to h5 and black we captures
the pawn here this position is sharp
quite clearly a black after long castles
maybe Queen to e7 there are alternatives
but this looks good this is a sharp
position it's interesting but black has
two bishops he will go Bishop d7 and
castles and has a good center so this is
a very good starting point to play for
win with black you know it's it's
imbalance and an interesting position
something very similar might happen if
white starts with Queen to h5 here black
however besides e 6 which is a decent
move and probably will transpose can
also take if he likes that takes takes
and then something like e 6 is also
possible just solidify the center put
the pieces out here and go for long
castles also white also can start with
the move III year after that black goes
96 and after Bishop f6 very likely to
happen after Knight f3 black walk go for
the pin after this this we my transpose
to what we have seen above however I
forgotten something I was a bit quick
there there is also the movie for I've
was close to forgetting that one this is
the far more aggressive looking move
yeah here black will take money for and
now white has to do something with his
deep one he can advance the pawn or take
on c5 taking on c5 is far more popular
and better after d5 black just goes f5
and keeps his paw and and this Bishop on
g7 will be a fantastic piece plus it's
an extra pawn I mean white has basically
no compensation him so he will taken and
here black has a choice he can support
his pawn keep it but allow this check
which is in fact far something like this
is quite nice for black actually it's
not a problem at all you just have to be
a little bit cautious with your King and
that has been moved but our central
pawns here are very very nice so if you
don't want to do that after sorry after
D takes this also Queen to a5 nothing
wrong with that white you normally
continue with something like this Queen
out here to h5 let's say Bishop g7 and
now maybe a check Jana can play Bishop
d7 or 96 with a sharp game
yeah f5 is possible sometimes keep that
Bishop those from boost or strong 1 g7
so yeah I think we can be happy with
that it's not like better for black but
certainly a good interesting position so
c5 is my move against the very softest
Bishop g5 and to keep it simple after
Bishop f4 I see no reason to refrain
from c5 either there are alternatives
yeah
six a six all kinds of moves but to keep
it simple why not see five it makes a
lot of sense first of all we are not
afraid of that move of course because we
are so check so this is not a problem at
all
however after white plays III and T
basically has two we are taking G for
it's looking very unattractive after III
and now black trades on T for here in
this position here black has to be a
little bit cautious with nod to b5 if
black is playing the routine move 96
after 95 it gets quite embarrassing as
we have no way to cover c7 so here black
as he wants to play 96 should invest one
move to play a six looks low but the
position here is basically a carrucan or
camo can sometimes have problems with
this ya with pronouncing German words in
English I should switch to the German
pronunciation which is correct but it's
very tricky for me to do somehow I tend
to say those German words it's some very
real English way and it sounds pretty
pretty wacky but it's not voluntarily I
have no idea how to get rid of it anyway
a six is a good move we prevent this and
in the exchange karo the night
absolutely does not belong on c3 so we
don't really mind to invest at a six
month which as I said SB 5 for minority
attack can be useful anyway it doesn't
really make them doesn't give black any
any issues that we have played a six
yeah this is my recommendation against
the very soft with Bishop f4 I think
after after these moves it's not really
necessarily to to know much more black
intends to play knight c6 possibly pin
here than e six and it's a very
sound healthy development I'm actually a
little bit puzzled why this line is not
played more often against Bishop f4
which is I mean it's not like very
fashionable but it has been played quite
a bit in rapid and blitz chess by by a
strong players even just to get
something different on the board and I
wonder why a six is not play more yeah
so this is the very soft so if we go
back to the initial moves after d5 if
they go d4 this is what I'm recommending
oh by the way hmm I actually forgot that
this so that's the black MIDI McGann but
that that takes us a really far away now
if we look at that I'm just why I'm
recording the video I'm getting aware of
that possibility man white could could
play that hmm well I've got something
that I can recommend first of all there
is the opinion that this move order
isn't good in the first place due to
Knight takes e4 which is maybe possible
but if you want a very simple
recommendation against this opening you
can take f3 and now it is perfectly okay
for black to take the pawn however when
I was looking at this a little bit form
well I I reckon I found out something
and I was looking at the the kurakin
opening that black actually has the move
c6 here which is very good actually
pretty good the the thing is white now
lacks a clear clear move what he wants
to do what he should do if he takes on
e4 with the pawn we play e5 and this is
already very nice for black yeah the
capture on e5 is pretty bad yeah yeah we
get this back and have a good structure
with this big pawn there or if white
plays Knight f3 recapture and something
like Knight takes Bishop before sees why
it's already struggling
black has excellent development efore is
weak and yeah it's very difficult for Y
to even keep a playable position here
yeah you can take with the Queen okay
that's possible
but after this and this and let's say 97
and tending 95 black is also very
comfortable and this is absolutely not a
position that a black Medina gambit fan
would like to play so FK x d4 is pretty
yeah it's not really great what else is
there if they I'm sorry for my accordion
if they develop their Bishop this one
something like this for example is bad
do 295 simply it doesn't do him any good
or Bishop g5 you can yeah just go h6 if
you like yeah be happy to return the
point I mean this kind of position is
good for black because we have good dark
square play so what do they do sometimes
they play this move and here black is
happy to play b5 this is just just a
very decent decent way to play like this
how is it continuing I'm kind of making
this up as I'm going along because I
looked at this like two years ago b5
Bishop e3
I think he's sixes the move because
after because again now White has some
problems finding moves here something
like this will give away the e4 pawn and
there is really no compensation there's
been a game by Nigel short with white
against Piraeus if I'm not mistaken
where black was yeah very comfortable
out of the opening so okay this is a bit
improvised but if you want something
against black pidemo this is a pretty
good line that c6 just decline it I
looked at this out of the kurakin
opening or caro-kann if you wonder how
that came about it was this line and
then I found out that Knight f6 is a
pretty decent move that transposes to
what we just looked at
okay so back to okay sorry
back to 193 okay d5 and what you will
get there quite often is Timothy form
yeah this is a way of making this in
some cases an independent opening if
here you are familiar with again
calc on c6 or the French defense ecigs
you can easily just transpose to that M
this is something that's possible on
either of six for some kind of elegance
defense one you can also take and after
Knight takes play something Scandinavian
style like 25 for example all those
moves are possible but they don't really
try to exploit what white is doing and I
think that this is possible not that
black is much better but I think it's
quite clear that after d4 it is white
who's probably fighting for equality the
knight is attacked sometimes they go
back to be one that doesn't look very
very active but it's not such a bad move
actually I think after 95 and Bishop C
form and I'd have 63 just normal
development Bishop d6 black must be fine
I mean Knight c3 and back cannot be
great but it doesn't look like why does
an in huge trouble yeah some possible
plan here can be to try to exchange that
Bishop it's the only really active
looking piece and other than that try to
expand on the Queen side as this is the
side where we have the space advantage
that b1 is very rare though they
normally go here yeah and other moves
are really bad I mean who goes to d5
there are actually some some games that
are that I've found with the move but it
is just just quite weird something that
in five it's already threatening c6 and
well yeah where do you go
ninety-two is the move now if I the move
order here's is important if they play
Knight f3 now normally Nigerians played
but this is also possible we play f6
this is the important move to remember
we don't play the knight out to c6 to
allow a possible pin with a later Bishop
b5 f6 first the idea is that after 93
which is transposing to 93 and move form
we play Bishop to e6 and here the Bishop
c4 move is just prevented we had just in
time to do that and this means that
white has some issues with this
development of that of that Bishop we
will explore this position a little bit
more when we look at night
g3 yeah here white also can choose an
entirely different way of development
with d3 keeping that Bishop back here
and fear carrying it I think the easiest
is to just play c5 and after f4 96 but 3
to support this ie 5 on with pieces the
most likely scenario is something like
this like g3 and now my recommendation
is to play something with f6 f6 Bishop
g2 not g7 this kind of thing this is
some kind of Kings Indian reversed where
we have this typical plain white has
King side prospects with some f5 and
black has the better play on the Queen
side what is important is black has not
cast lot yet not Castle short and I
think that in many cases here black can
do without castling and keep the king a
little bit in the center trying to play
on the Queen side without getting
without giving white a clear target on
the King side this is often quite
irritating for the white player wants to
go for that Kings I play against the
black king so this is definitely a good
interesting position and
93 is the most common move and here we
have this important venecia to make sure
that the bishop is not coming down here
Nydia 3 looks very logical and f6 yeah
now this is a little bit of a problem
now for why how does he develop his
bishop to some active square I mean okay
you can play a Bishop e2 castles and so
on but black is very happy I think with
this space something like C 5 cancels 9
c 6 this is just black being white in a
way el you have a typical position that
the white player has with more space and
and easy an easy game let's say why does
basically suffering from this
disadvantage of space a little bit it's
not terribly bad but it's not very
attractive either what white sometimes
tries is to move c3 to attack that
center here black has an interesting
choice you can play the routine let's
say c5 which is yeah very very easy to
play and just develop like shall you go
here later a 6 and then the 97 comes to
c6 this is very ok and playable or you
can play the more ambitious move d3 this
can lead to some wacky positions if
white tries to do things here like 9 h4
and yeah it's it's it's very very tough
it's something like c5 we have to check
knight c6 Queen B 5 all of a sudden
never see two points hanging but well is
that a good position for white I doubt
it yeah but it's so kind of messy yeah
you have to kind of be up for that you
know that if you play d3 you're probably
in good shape but it leads to messy
positions but c5 is also simple and good
sometimes white players try that the
check here to get the bishop around here
but we also don't mind
this so much a normal move like night to
a 6 or 9:27 it is okay for black him
something like this for example if they
go here we can take and just develop
here or if you go to a six there is this
additional option after Bishop b3 to
take take and play d3 it's also
interesting try to make this a very bad
piece an alternative here's also the
move
h5 this is a motif that you should keep
in mind it can be handy quite often
because the night on g3 doesn't have
clearly good squares to go to for
example after Bishop b3 and I can take
and push even further with h4 and here
Knight f5 h3 can be quite a mess but
probably a mess where black is in pretty
good shape yeah so Knight c3 this is not
a bad move at all it just has relatively
little independent value the independent
lines are normally not particularly
great yeah if we go back to 2 here we
have to look at d4 and e4 and other
moves frankly speaking yeah don't make
more sense we looked at f4 briefly where
black can just develop even d4 as it
could move the knight it's just not good
there in connection with their form or
white can of course play like g3 but
again after this why this is going back
and that cannot be great
so mostly after d5 they play a form or
deform the e4 is the more frequent move
and then we get to the lines that we
have looked at in this video
yeah I hope you like the overview you
don't need to be scared off 93 but if
you want to play ambitiously that D 5 D
4 for example of
efore ng4 can be a very good way to go
yeah okay I hope you enjoyed it thanks
for watching